it's one of her most important
constitutional roles and every one of
her 14 prime ministers has been
appointed at buckingham palace now for
the first time balmoral where she's on
her summer break is where the queen will
hand powered her 15th duty as ever
coming first
the queen has taken a very singular view
of her role in that she's very much
the queen and views herself between in a
total sense we may need to look at just
loosening that structure and it also
prepares for the transition
this is what we're used to seeing the
current prime minister making that short
drive to the palace to resign their
successor very close behind it had been
thought the queen was again going to
travel back her current prime minister
more than happy to do what's best for
her
i don't talk about my conversations with
the the queen no prime minister ever
does but i can tell you that uh we will
certainly make sure that the
arrangements for uh the handover will
fit totally around her and whatever
whatever she wants
at 96 this is a monarch who isn't as
agile anymore the walking stick was
again on hand at her last public
engagement in july
the palace aren't suggesting that she's
getting any worse instead hinting it's
all about being practical making sure
everyone knows the plans for tuesday
even if it's not clear exactly who's
going to be traveling to scotland
historian tessa dunlop told me she
believes the current political turmoil
may well have made the queen even more
determined to be seen
it's a reminder of course that we very
much still do have an active head of
state firmly engaged with her
constitutional duties and a realist
about where and when she can execute
them
in the past people have been squeamish
about any hints of change or handing
over
now it is very much a common sense
approach her family willing to step in
but only when she wants them to
rihanna mills sky news